you've had great success with the web
series for Mary Olson you have a Twitter
page from Mary who tweets like on dating
single life pizza and then an equal news
I believe says about your film that
looking for a good place to laugh till
you drop the selling is the right place
for you so we'd love to hear about your
comedy how do you make a scene funny
thoughts hmm we we actually example from
the movie there was the opening one of
the opening scenes of the film just I
couldn't crack it the one with Simon and
Elena yeah and I and I just kept
rewriting and rewriting and rewriting it
at this point I was I've been working on
the script by myself and I and like
night before we shot it we sat down
together and she said flip it this way
and do this and then she figured out
sort of just the way of doing it so you
tell me how it being funny you can't
really teach it it's just sort of it's
an instinct um and if you're a bit helps
make dick jokes that helps yes yes my
team i turning red is there I'm a good
about yourself to dictating language
yeah you want to talk about being a
female comedian um yeah that's weird uh
we'll go to comedy shows and I'll be the
only girl backstage a lot of times it's
gotten better in the last five years or
so but people will get up and people oh
there's two of em oh there's a girl and
I think in our culture it's not that
women aren't funny it's that people
aren't used to laughing at women and I
was um he was at the comic book store
and I was bored so I was reading
magazines and there was this this years
ago in a magazine awesome this
thing about someone complaining about 30
rock had just come out and they were
complaining that Tina Fey why couldn't
her character have been a strong woman
and why do we have to make fun of her
all the time and it's like you're not
getting it she is helping women because
we are laughing at her
you know having her weight issues and
being gross and and doing the great
things that she does on that show and
and it's not bringing women down to to
laugh at her it's it's bringing us up
because when people get used to laughing
at women than female comedians will do
better and there'll be more of them and
people like Adam Carolla won't whip out
that they don't think that women are is
funny so as opposed to the woman going
you're so crazy you guys stop it not
playing that character a lot in sitcoms
being the the straight man which in our
act I I tend to play a straight man she
plays the wacky wacky kill you're taller
well yeah that helps what do you think
it is that society is uncomfortable with
women being funny I've never sasaeng do
you think it's maybe they're upstaging
men in society I'm sure that's part of
it and I mean there's so many reasons
and it's so complicated I think I better
is yes impatient please do well if I
were going to answer I would say that
yeah I think it's rude and sexism I
think that you know comedians of
male-dominated profession because you
have a lot of it attracts a lot of
sexist men and and it's you know it's
like a naked man is funny a naked woman
is usually exploitive or not funny
unless she sadness yes that's hilarious
um but yeah it's just this it's this
thing we're men are threatened by mm-hmm
well from listening to the WTF podcast
with marc maron on my favorite I guess
he talks about most comedians go up
there to work on some type of issue of
their own and they work on it through
the crowd right so do you think maybe
people can't handle women having quote
unquote issues or whatever it is because
they're supposed to be just like manners
I mean it's it's not just comedians it's
it's women and stories and in general
we're used to you know I can go and
watch the bourne identified entity and
identify what Jason Bourne but if you
put a woman in a lead character I mean
you know we think that man
not going to want to see it because
little boys aren't brought up to
identify with women they're they're not
I don't know a lot of probably little
boys are reading the Hunger Games and
that's probably going to help because
they can identify the Katniss or um
things like that but in our society men
aren't put in the position to identify
with women so any movie with women in it
is a chick flick well there was an
interesting article about um like female
action movies with female action
characters and when they don't do well
they say well movies with female female
leads and action movies don't work
people don't want to see them but like
male action movie doesn't do well people
don't say well they don't want see me
don't want to see them and men in an
action movie but that's like the go-to
thing for if if a female driven vehicle
doesn't do well and and if you just look
at something like the bechdel test you
know which isn't supposed to you know
malign any single film but just the fact
that so few movies pass it at all is
absurd and and points out that there you
know women are 51 percent of the
population and that's ridiculous that
most movies don't have a scene with two
women talking to each other for more
than 30 seconds about something in a man
named characters I think other than I me
then yeah so I mean that's just
ridiculous right I don't think the
selling passes the Bechdel test it
doesn't but it does have some strong
female characters yeah that was
important to me I didn't know about the
bechdel test when I wrote that so didn't
even realize that I was
institutionalized thing where I didn't
even realize I was doing well also it's
not meant to judge individual movies and
the lead character in the movies I mean
the story focuses around him so I
forgive you
thank you how bad we made them suffer on
camera what's my reason for being here
you